[Musique]
il était une fois et il est encore caché
parmi les glaciers de l'antarctique
montagne creuse qui selon la légende
garde le secret sur les origines
de l'homme
au coeur de la montagne se trouve une grotte
qui ressemble à l'intérieur d'une coquille
noyer et sur ses murs sont gravés des dieux
symboles qui racontent l'histoire
de l'humanité
[Musique]
au milieu de la grotte dans le silence plus
l'absolu domine une table massive
rotonde creusée dans la roche
est un lieu sacré est cette table la
noble objectif de ne pas avoir de premier a
dernière place parce que les êtres vivants
ils sont tous égaux face à la luxure
le créateur de notre univers
brava est l'une des entités appartenant à
une civilisation cosmique infiniment
évolué si avancé qu'il a échappé au
les limites de notre compréhension
nous, les terriens, considérons ces entités
comme des dieux parce que nous sommes trop
arriérés pour comprendre comment et pourquoi
ont conçu la réalité tangible e
les étoiles
qu'avec leur énergie
permettre la vie sur certaines planètes dieux
divers univers
[Musique]
parce qu'il y a d'autres univers
également composé de milliards de
planètes étoiles galaxies certains dieux
qui sont habités par d'autres êtres et
d'autres types d'hommes
mais dans notre univers
la conception de la matière vivante est
été confié à la cupidité
la légende veut qu'il en ait envie
il a somnolé dans une dimension sans
espace et intemporel quand
soudain le son de om
prolongé et puissant l'a réveillé de
commencer
[Musique]
soutien-gorge mais savait qu'il reviendrait à son
moment mais il était encore confus, il ne savait pas
ce qu'il faut faire
puis sa femme saraswati que le
divinité féminine sans laquelle rien
peut être réalisé a suggéré qu'il reste
silencieux et à écouter
tellement immergé dans le son de l'ombre
conçu l'ordre cosmique
un ensemble de lois physiques biologiques
et l'éthique qui gardent la vie pour le
durée d'un cycle renouvelable
sans cesse
appelé le jour de brahma
[Musique]
parmi les nombreux êtres déjà complets et
perfectionner toutes leurs facultés que vous
magiquement manifesté dans le nôtre
l'univers sur la planète terre est apparu
l'homme est une créature dotée d'un
conscience et triade qui l'accompagne dans
toute sa vie et cela lui permet de
atteindre le sommet de la conscience
les symboles gravés dans cette montagne creuse
ils ne sont perçus en vision que par
très peu de mystiques qui les gardent
secrets
pourtant tous les croyants athées je
philosophes et scientifiques du monde
ils prétendent connaître les origines
de l'homme
certains pensent qu'il a été créé par
une divinité pour gouverner la terre
d'autres nient l'intervention divine
expliquer que l'homme est un animal
traitant et que son apparence est plus
trivialement en raison d'une évolution
naturel sinon aléatoire
l'une des plus anciennes théories qui
medica est né en inde il y a plus de 5000 ans
il y a et est décrit dans les quatre livres de
voir écrit en sanskrit
[Musique]
les vedas déclarent que chaque personne est
doté d'une conscience éternelle et quand
le corps de cette personne meurt le sien
la conscience se réincarne dans le corps d'un
nouveau née
[Musique]
les textes védiques mentionnent également les avatars
des divinités venues sur terre pour
expliquer aux humains comment ça marche
l'ordre cosmique
et comment améliorer votre vie
compter sur les pouvoirs de la spiritualité
une autre culture
tout aussi ancien et sumérien
[Musique]
la différence entre les deux cultures est que
celui que vous voyez est basé sur des textes
connu et étudié depuis 5000 ans
tandis que le sumérien a été découvert
au XIXe siècle et ses textes gravés sur
les tablettes d'argile sont connues et
étudié depuis un peu plus d'un siècle
[Musique]
la littérature supposera que les dieux
des géants venus du ciel à bord
les machines volantes sont arrivées sur
terre pour exploiter sa richesse
exploitation minière
leur équipage était composé de
nobles et de subordonnés et quand ceux-ci
a refusé de travailler pour la dernière fois dans
les mines les nobles les remplaçaient par des dieux
Des primates africains qui se sont améliorés
génétiquement modifié pour en faire un nouveau
l'espèce s'appelle l'homme le terrien
[Musique]
autrement dit si les géants subalternes
ils ne s'étaient pas révoltés
l'homme n'apparaîtrait jamais
selon le récit sumérien, ces
astronautes géants ont vécu des milliers de
années
ils possédaient une technologie supérieure et
ils ont donc été pris pour acquis
divinité des premiers hommes qui furent
très dur
mais pourtant flatté d'être
considérés comme des dieux les géants
ils traitaient les hommes comme des esclaves
ils ont exigé l'obéissance absolue e
ils ont tué et désobéi
c'est ainsi que les notions de
châtiment divin et religieux
[Musique]
ayant cependant des difficultés
respirer sur une planète qui n'était pas
leurs les géants ont été forcés de
vivre au sommet des montagnes où
l'air est plus rare
mais ces endroits n'étaient guère
accessible par les humains alors je
les géants ont amélioré certains hommes
primitifs formant une lignée d'hommes
supérieur loin des mythes et construit
des immeubles très hauts sur lesquels
top leur a donné l'ordre de faire
suivre les esclaves
[Musique]
puis ils ont formé les premières nations et
ils ont dicté à leurs amis qui sont les
ancêtres des sumériens les textes gravés sur
comprimés
dans ces textes les géants me décrivent
leurs voyages dans le système solaire et les
production de l'homme faite pour eux
image et ressemblance
[Musique]
même les anciens textes égyptiens mentionnent
divinités géantes semblables à celles
sur les mers qui ont créé les premiers hommes
dans la Grèce antique plus de deux mille ans
tard puis il y a trois mille ans aussi homer
et desio mentionnent des divinités qui
ils ressemblent beaucoup à ceux sur mere et ça
créer si le premier homme et le premier
femme
[Musique]
le premier à mentionner un seul dieu e
Zarathoustra un mystique des temps anciens
la perse prêchant à la suite
de la vie humaine au paradis
en enfer
cette idée est immédiatement partagée par
peuple juif naissant qui depuis lors
embrasser la foi monothéiste
[Musique]
les textes hébreux précédant celui-ci
la conversion raconte les mêmes faits
gravé deux mille ans plus tôt dans le
Tablettes sumériennes
ils excitent donc des géants vénérés dans
moyen-orient les appelant elohim
[Musique]
mais après l'avènement du monothéisme, ces
les textes sont en bas pour compiler les
bible juive un livre saint où si
affirme que le seul créateur élohim
de l'univers de la terre et de l'homme
le hub est le dieu guerrier des juifs
on ne sait pas si les divinités prennent le relais
Indien
juif
grec
chinois et les autres divinités mentionnées dans le
les mythes du monde antique sont les mêmes
parce qu'ils sont très similaires mais pas
ils se comportent tous de la même manière
régnait dans la vallée de l'indus
spiritualité
guerre au moyen-orient
la culture en Chine
en egypte le culte de l'au-delà
quatre siècles plus tard au Népal
bouddha suit la tradition védique
arguant que la vie n'a pas de commencement dans
une fin et que les gens se réincarnent
jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent des esprits et des terriens
exempt de souffrance
en chine meme lao tze a une conception
cycle d'existence où l'homme ne
il surgit en ce que le sien a toujours existé
la tâche est de revenir sur scène
origine qui l'a généré
[Musique]
six cents ans plus tard en palestine le juif
Inspirateur romain du christianisme
Paul de Tarse
déclare l'existence d'un nouveau dieu
Jésus
[Musique]
homme et dieu jésus a été envoyé
terre afin que son sacrifice sur
traverser pour commencer une nouvelle humanité
basé sur le pardon et l'amour du vin
600 autres années passent et moins
l'influence de la culture juive voisine
est né en Arabie à la religion
monothéiste de l'islam dont le seul dieu
aussi créateur de l'univers de
la terre et l'homme est très similaire à l'ave
le dieu des juifs
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de divinités mentionnées par les différents
textes sacrés du monde mais bien qu'il y ait
sont des preuves historiques de leur
existence
leurs fidèles les vénèrent en se fondant
sur ses perceptions intérieures et plus
les conservateurs utilisent la violence pour
convertir ceux qui n'y croient pas
[Musique]
du XVIIIe siècle à la suite de
atrocités perpétrées par l'église
catholique avec l'inquisition le dieu
la spiritualité est contestée en europe
la théorie matérialiste est née
[Musique]
cette théorie soutient que la création
de l'univers est due à une explosion
original
que la vie est née d'une combinaison
chimie aléatoire
et que chaque être vivant est le produit
de l'évolution spontanée de l'être
du même ordre qui le précède
[Musique]
la théorie la plus célèbre est celle de darwin
qui contourne la question de l'origine
de la vie en l'expliquant par l'évolution
d'une cellule primordiale qui a ensuite
forment des corps plus complexes
bien que darwin lui-même admette que
cette théorie a des difficultés ad
appliquer à l'homme
aussi la bague n'a jamais été retrouvée
ne manque aucune plante et personne
animal
[Musique]
doutes sur l'évolution darwinienne
découlent également d'études menées sur
certains organes tels que les yeux et les ailes
qui n'ont pas du tout évolué parce que
ils ont toujours été parfaitement actifs
Depuis le début
contribuer à la défense du darwinisme
principalement les Britanniques qui recherchent
colonisé les autres continents e
traduit leurs œuvres littéraires plus
des personnes importantes ont pris soin de ne pas
divulguez-les
en particulier la littérature hindoue
héritier du médical parce que son
révélations de nature spirituelle
bouleverserait la culture occidentale
d'origine anglo-saxonne
maintenant devenu un matérialiste e
scientifique
en fait, on a découvert que les ancêtres
des hindous maîtrisaient tous les
disciplines scientifiques bien avant
Les Grecs considérés comme les pères de la connaissance
il y a cinq mille ans, les textes védiques
ils ont mentionné la manipulation génétique
les chiffres et zéro puis copié à partir de
Arabes
ils ont mentionné des machines volantes qui
ils ont parcouru l'espace et soutenu
l'existence d'autres civilisations humaines qui
a précédé l'actuel
[Musique]
ces civilisations étaient dotées de
technologies bien supérieures à celles
actuel
leurs traces sont encore visibles dans
cette énorme construction qui est la nôtre
les ingénieurs ne peuvent pas correspondre et tout
cela réduit la primauté de
Culture occidentale
[Musique]
il semble que la civilisation avant la
notre ère mondiale et pacifique avec un
seule langue en sanskrit tenue aujourd'hui
la base de nombreuses langues éteintes
[Musique]
la littérature médicale l'explique bien
des particuliers l'existence des autres
univers
de leurs galaxies de planètes habitées
d'autres humanoïdes dont certains ont
déjà visité la terre
de la conscience et de la triade qui les anime
et des intelligences cosmiques qu'ils sont
à la base de la création
les vedas mentionnent aussi les évolutions et les
involutions des univers le
apparitions et extinctions massives de
actions parallèles
effets quantiques
temps non linéaire et autres notions a
pour le moins fascinant
[Musique]
l'un d'eux explique que les cycles de chaque
la civilisation humaine a quatre ans comme l'âge
de l'homme
enfance et jeunesse
maturité
et la vieillesse
le premier cycle et la préhistoire
la seconde est la protohistoire avec
l'invention de l'écriture
dans ces deux cycles ce sont les divinités
femmes pour régner en paix
recherche intérieure
au troisième et au quatrième cycle, ils sont
les dieux mâles et leurs armes e
régner
c'est la période des guerres comme la quatrième
cycle dans lequel nous vivons actuellement
et c'est aussi la confrontation entre les
pouvoirs du mal et ceux du bien avec moi
bien qui triomphe au dernier moment et
préparer le terrain pour les quatre nouveaux
des cycles où tout recommence
très important pour le roi de et aussi le
régime végétarien à base de crudités
et les fruits indispensables pour un juste
l'équilibre physique et mental et pour la
respect pour la vie de nos frères
animaux que s'ils sont produits e
massacrés en masse pour se nourrir
ils empoisonnent l'air et l'eau ainsi que
provoquer des maladies dégénératives et mortelles
en effet
manger de la viande c'est assimiler
une substance toxique que les animaux
y compris l'homme et mis dans le sang
quand ils se rendent compte qu'ils sont en train d'être tués
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans cet instant de terreur un
glande libre dans le sang du
victime de cette drogue qui continue son
effet sur l'organisme de ceux qui en mangent
remuer dans le cœur et l'esprit jusqu'à
les faire éclater
[Musique]
cela était connu de Pythagore et des
érudits de leur temps qu'ils étaient
végétariens et qui avaient pris un repère
de la spiritualité se consacre à méditer un
calmer l'esprit en acquérant cette connaissance
scientifiques et initiatiques qui les ont
rendu célèbre
[Musique]
le dernier mais non le moindre de
notions médicales et la récitation du om
qui permet aux corps humains de se réinitialiser
vos propres vibrations jusqu'à ce que vous les fassiez
optimal favorisant ainsi la vie de qui
le récite et de ceux qui le fréquentent
au contraire le matérialisme occidental
et la foi dans le dieu de l'argent désormais exporté
à travers le monde ils tendent vers la décadence
de l'humanité comme le prétend le
les scientifiques modernes selon lesquels
nos stands de QI
régresser
l'intelligence est définie comme la
capacité à raisonner sur les difficultés e
les résoudre par des actions concrètes
mais au quatrième cycle ces capacités sont
délégué et intelligence artificielle
dont le but est de remplacer l'homme
avec des robots
reproduire l'intelligence humaine
ils appellent ça le progrès mais c'est pour
Vraiment
il est logique qu'en supprimant l'homme le
compétences intellectuelles et manuelles
nous le rendons stupide et c'est juste ce que
ça se passe
il reste à déterminer s'il s'agit d'un
le déclin naturel ou la volonté de
quelqu'un qui agit par tous les moyens
pour que ceux qui deviendront stupides
veut subjuguer
la question n'est pas triviale
il n'y aurait même pas besoin de
divinités ou extraterrestres pour le faire
une élite d'hommes riches suffirait e
sans scrupules qu'ils ont ces
ambitions alors lesquelles devraient être faites
qui prodest les anciens Romains ont dit
qui profite sinon qui gagne
[Musique]
l'histoire ancienne et l'histoire actuelle sont
plein de gens méchants qui ont
conditionné la vie des peuples pour
devenir riche
[Musique]
avec de l'argent on peut faire beaucoup de choses
comme allonger le sien
vie
ceci est déjà décrit dans les mythes anciens
car s'il est vrai que le temps est cyclique
tout revient
aujourd'hui ces quelques milliardaires qui gouvernent
le monde concentre son attention
sur le transhumanisme qui augmente la
capacités physiques et mentales
en plus de supprimer la vieillesse
le leur, bien sûr, certainement pas celui-là
du reste de l'humanité qui ne peut
se le permettre
même la bible accepte une durée de
beaucoup de vie centenaire pour les patriarches
de souche adamique qui étaient peu nombreux et
très riche gardé une apparence
juvénile jusqu'à la mort et leur
les femmes accouchent avec succès
centenaires
selon la bible en palestine à ceux
fois il y avait des yahvé qui aimaient les autres dieux
Les Sumériens exigeaient des sacrifices humains et
il traitait les gens comme des animaux
mais il a préféré les Adams plutôt qu'eux
une fois qu'ils considéraient les gens ordinaires
comme des êtres inférieurs
il semble presque qu'aujourd'hui la relation entre
les anciens dieux extraterrestres sont les leurs
privilégié et le reste de l'humanité oui
répéter
cette idée est d'actualité car depuis quelques mois
il y a à la nasa a officiellement admis
l'existence hors de tout doute du web
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
anciennement appelés OVNIS
sont des objets volants ramassés par
radars militaires et civils tandis que
traverser le ciel et les eaux des dieux
des mers à des vitesses qui échappent aux lois
physique connue
et ce ne sont pas des objets terrestres sinon
leurs fondations seraient facilement
repéré par des satellites espions
chaque pouce du monde
[Musique]
l'un des directeurs de centres les plus estimés
les Israéliens de l'espace révèlent même
que les États-Unis et l'État de
Israël sont en contact depuis de nombreuses années
avec des extraterrestres
installé sur mars et la lune
on est dans la pure science-fiction
mais encore plus sagaces les conquérants du
passé comme jules césar charlemagne ou
Charles Quint
aurait considéré comme de la science-fiction
vol d'un avion
encore moins celle d'un missile terrestre
avion ou navette
[Musique]
il n'en reste pas moins qu'extra terrestre ou pas
99 % de la population
monde et aujourd'hui subjugué par un par
centaine d'hommes très riches qui
ils aspirent au pouvoir total
et pour ce faire, ils doivent me faire taire
peuples prêts des grandes civilisations
anciens les seuls qui ont les compétences
intellectuelle et spirituelle pour les obscurcir
s'opposer à leur culture
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'inde irak la
Grèce, Italie, France et Chine
sont parmi tous les pays de la terre je
les plus touchés par les dirigeants actuels
Ennemis anglo-saxons du spiritisme
et défenseurs de la théorie matérialiste
basé sur l'économie
[Musique]
le sous-continent indien a été envahi
elle est divisée en deux pays rendus très pauvres
l'inde et le pakistan, berceaux de
Civilisation spirituelle védique
L'Irak a été détruit et avec lui le
traces rappelant la grande première
civilisation humaine qui se moque des sumériens
même pas le contenu des comprimés
[Musique]
Grèce berceau de la civilisation
L'Union européenne a été pillée et placée en
genou
L'Italie est devenue un laboratoire où
l'élite mondialiste peut tester jusqu'où
il est possible de serrer l'étau
car c'est ici qu'est né l'empire romain
l'humanisme et la renaissance e
surtout la religion catholique
où il y a encore des cardinaux aujourd'hui
qui défendent la vraie spiritualité
Chrétien ennemi du matérialisme
si l'Italie tombe et que la porte s'ouvre e
on peut dire que l'expérience mondiale est un succès
immédiatement après l'Italie, ce sera au tour de
France
car l'héritier historique des nouveautés
La culture italienne et est dangereux
parce que ses gens très pragmatiques et
utilisé pour se rebeller avec des armes
[Applaudissements]
chine berceau du plus ancien sur le
nounou vu a d'abord été drogué
à l'oeil puis exploité en forçant
travail sous-payé et enfin
combattu quand ça devenait trop
riche
aujourd'hui la nouvelle alliance anglo-saxonne
composé des états-unis royaume-uni
canada australie et nouvelle-zélande
dirige ses bombes atomiques vers
Chine
reste la russie qui est une nation
chrétien très croyant et riche en
combustibles
mais c'est trop vaste pour risquer
l'envahir
Les anglo-saxons sont plutôt intelligents
ne pas faire les mêmes erreurs que
Napoléon et Hitler
puis ils le menacent en armant les pays qui
l'entourer
et le frapper avec l'embargo une mesure
administrative et militaire qui empêche
la libre circulation des marchandises et la
croissance économique
[Musique]
bref, ce quatrième cycle qui est le nôtre
ressemble à un enfer
la classe moyenne disparaît
et les pauvres augmentent considérablement
la natalité est étouffée et avec elle la
développement nécessaire à la maintenance
de la société
des millions de jeunes Africains viennent
versé en Europe
déstabiliser leur culture et
notre
les grèves politiquement correctes
chemin ridicule vers la littérature
l'homosexualité est un laissez-passer
le succès
[Musique]
les lois constitutionnelles sont ignorées e
droits humains et sociaux conquis
avec deux siècles de luttes syndicales
sont supprimés
et chaos
ou comme diraient les beaus de et de bataille
finale entre les forces du mal et celles
du bien
[Musique]
comment ça va finir raconter l'histoire
et l'art
La peinture de Raphaël est bien connue
sanzio où l'archange michael
écraser la tête de satan
symbolisé par un dragon
on sait également que lorsque peu
privilégiés sont abordés par un
les gens en colère finissent généralement mal
comme cela s'est déjà produit avec la révolution
Français et avec tous les autres
révolutions du monde
[Musique]
cependant pour sortir du chaos ils existent
d'autres solutions
Autres méthodes
[Musique]
gandhi par exemple en s'appuyant sur
Sagesse védique avec non-violence
persuadé 300 millions d'Indiens ad
bras croisés
forçant les Britanniques à revenir
Maison
[Musique]
nelson mandela a été enfermé dans un
cellule pendant 30 ans et en est sorti
fortifié grâce aux études voir
qui lui donna la force de
vaincre la ségrégation raciale
martin luther king a embrassé al
vérisme pour obtenir la parité
droits des afro-américains
et autrefois tous les grands initiés
comme Dante Alighieri
pic de la mirandole
Léonard de Vinci
et michelangelo a suivi les principes
les fondamentaux de la culture voile
les représenter dans leurs œuvres
conclure tous les êtres vivants
du plus grand au plus petit ils sont
créatures infiniment complexes
impossible de rester en vie sans
un projet initial très élaboré e
cohérent qu'aucun scientifique ne pourra
ne réalise jamais
[Musique]
pourtant quelque chose d'immensément
le supérieur l'a fait et continue de le faire
le dire serait déjà un point de
assez de départ
[Musique]
peut-être que la meilleure chose à faire est
redécouvrir le pouvoir de l'ancien
la spiritualité consacre
qui conseille de surmonter les difficultés
régime végétarien et jeu d'acteur
du om dont l'action vit et favorise
contact avec l'intelligence cosmique
[Musique]
essayez et le monde sera à nouveau
certainement mieux